all right so we're back with our first
viewings and we are going what do we
watch Viva rock Vegas yeah I probably
deserve that uh we haven't seen this
what we make fun of it a lot it's sort
of an hour all those infamous bad
sequels but we have not seen it so if
you'll be good he were just jumping to
conclusions mom I you know what I got a
gun I will bet you ten bucks right now
that we are now I am NOT going to take
you off of FF I do we have like The
Flintstones I don't even like the
cartoon I like with it for TV and
everything and opening up a prime-time
animation all about abusing poor
prehistoric animals by making them do
household that is the only funny part
and the country club I love that part
here we go this is our first review of
our viewing review whatever you I call
it of Viva rock Vegas all crying shit oh
no aah Alan Cumming is most terrifying
roles instead of a necklace this is the
stuff of nightmares a Stephen Baldwin
like usual suspect Stephen Baldwin or
slumming it pure flake Stephen Baldwin
come on we're late for God's club okay
we've had aliens cavemen and Las Vegas
I'm sure all of these are gonna conduct
beautifully Oh
who gave this very unfunny MADtv sketch
a lot of money you know the CGI I'm mad
dinosaur is not that impressive
actually the scary thing is it is
rubbles pretty good I think it's kind of
the role he was born to play good
dropping out of drop it on him
drop it on him there you go and Wow
actually animatronic yeah I've actually
thoroughly impressed as Wilma yeah
that's a weird choice
incoming message from the big giant head
you've been miscast she's immediately
like what am i doing in the press I
think those bit moment where she
realized and I picked the wrong agent is
for any man listen to me
guest rock I'm not gonna sleep tonight
honestly riding that dinosaur
rollercoaster looks like the most
interesting thing in the booth I'm not
sure I'd do that for an hour how are
they filming it you don't have celluloid
I need to know this is gonna be fun huh
it's Sally and he just took such a fan
John Lithgow
maybe this is some of that create a look
at them that at least my man gets lucky
once
it's a lobster rock root zone episode
where she gets a starring role in a
Flintstone yeah you know I'll give it
this there's yet to be a guy from dune
with business plan that makes no sense
to screw up over I don't know where it's
going
that actor has a name it's Kyle a
trading okay okay just over that hill
there shooting Breaking Bad her mother
is corruptible it looks like it really
this only has a 3.5 out of 10 stars on
IMDB that seems pretty high
[Laughter]
and that will come together like huh the
music told me because what what what
I'm gonna go United Airlines on your ass
um that's a horse dick you put on his
plane
oh yeah that's a fish yeah cool cool
cool rock Vegas on this is definitely a
ride at Universal look at you ride the
car in and then Stephen Baldwin is
literally there not a micronic that's it
was work soon we'll see him for the
pathetic primitive primate he really is
ah now we have the bullshit guy trying
to advertise okay talk a while Lahore
I'm afraid of infantry so are they like
floats for the Rose Bowl parade
so either deck on flowers there I just
found out what calamari means Rosie old
oh I see quite an impressive down dress
that Mommy is messy but you want me as
the activist
look at the seismic well I don't know
where this is going oh where did that
come from I am just shocked that's the
route they went with that Oh cry walking
this no it's ok I'm just wiping my
creepy Mossberg breath wait it came out
hold on have you excuse me I'm going to
the bathroom to use the procedure really
working uptight a of all the B's sort of
off of Titanic you're ripping off that
one like arguably the worst scene in the
movie would have been so much more
amazing if this movie came out first so
we could say Titanic Viva rock Vegas I'm
systematically poisoning the dinosaurs
water supply our entire species will be
extinct legitimately funny
the writers snaps a fucking out of 140
jobs plus I gotta be me
whoever's up doing all this beautiful
bubble bubble you will get out coming
like Oh clearly but we're makeup on him
you look at Steven bald is like what
makeup to define it no that's just how
you
hey I might be out of a job tomorrow
brother that has a nest egg you did know
that was getting a little too Dumbo for
me it's amazing how much it just so look
like he's there yeah yeah I'm really
something this is the only time where
Stephen Baldwin really looks like he's
looking at something cuz this is
probably what he sees every day honestly
I think I would rather watch the Geico
caveman succumb than this don't say
things you can't take back
I don't know and they're shorter cuz it
looks like that why'd you give him too
I know what hypo head on with the show
this is it it's not the line of work for
you everybody's getting AIDS and shit
and somebody appear flicks ABBA's and
said you know what we need him for our
Christian brother you know I'd be driven
to Christ after this movement there is
not a lot
is he a dragon fruit what is that you he
looks like how big these are made just
all the spur to the headache has the
interesting thing they had a last track
for this exactly like the show but they
could even get people to pay classical
luck and now I must be released you from
shit oh shut up shut up shut up ah is it
better six minutes of credits less that
that many people wanted their name
attached to this okay ultimate question
is it worse than the first one I feel
like this one have more color to it than
the first one this one have more color
to a thing this is scary I feel like
this one felt shorter yeah it did have
that one funny dinosaur line and I can't
think of one lap in the first one cells
moving Gazoo will haunt my nightmares
yeah terrified Oh movie stupid just
stupid dumb movie Oh
I said listen to say yeah say to the
dumb Rotten Tomatoes 25% for the record
Donald Trump right now I think is
sitting at 36%
from is doing better than this movie
than what by 11% well what what can we
say but uh it it's a living will have a
gay or duck or does
you